this is why men do everything they do
men buy the faster car not to drive any
faster because of status is why we want
bigger house we don't give a [ __ ] where
we live it's because of status so I want
to go to the gym and get big and strong
because of status everything we do is
about status is why I want the better
jobs so I want more money so I want to
be respected so what's the number one
thing we want our female to give us
status that's what we want so she can
give us status by being beautiful that's
one thing she can do but another thing
she could do is if I turn up home and I
come home with my boys and she says I'll
cook you all a steak that's status
that's all my boys going Ross you just
been out all night and she's here and
she's going to cook for all of us and
she'll clean up and tidy up boom that's
the kind of girl a man's not going to
want to lose because it makes him look
good
status suck a dick blah blah blah listen
they can only be sucked in so many ways
I mean and